hi i'm keanu reeves i'm alex winter
we're here with buzzfeed to take a quiz
to find out if we're more
bill or ted from bill and ted's
excellent adventure
and bill and ted's bogus journey and
bill and ted face the music
and bill and ted's breakfast cereal
question one if you were in a world
saving band which instrument would you
most
like to play well there's guitar drums
harmonica
and singer yeah i'm gonna take guitar
all right i'll do drums because
i don't mean why not what word do you
hope your closest friends use to
describe you
loyal kind funny ambitious
i'd say kind for mine yeah i'm gonna
take kind as well
if you had to win a popular board game
against oh i don't know
death which game do you feel you'd have
the best chance of
dominating i know which one you're going
to pick no you don't you have a lower
estimation of your chess abilities that
you actually don't
make a battleship brother oh for god's
sake if i do twister that's lame because
i already beat death a twister once
well then that's a good one if you want
to beat him again i guess that's true
i'll take twister pick the 90s slang
you'd most like to make a comeback
bogus as if the bomb
easy for me i would pick bogus i don't
like any of those other three
yeah that's the bomb as if
booyah bogus oh i'm gonna do bogus as
well
which of the following colors speak more
to your overall vibe
green blue red or purple
i'm blue i guess yeah i'm gonna take
green it's not easy being green
i know that's my been my whole problem
my whole life what are you most likely
to be doing at a party
chatting with friends dancing eating
looking for the exit
this is a total giveaway if i answer
this one honestly well no doesn't it
depend if it's
like if you're having fun at the party
you know if you're having fun at the
party
yeah you're doing everything but looking
for the exit and if you're not
having fun at the party you're looking
for the exit that's true
well then i want to be at a good party
where i'm dancing yeah and i
i want to be chatting with my friends
and finally pick a classic rock album to
blast
as you save the world there's no wild
stallions albums here that's not fair
back in black ac dc dark side of the
moon nick floyd thriller michael jackson
abbey road the beatles
what do you got reeves oh my gosh you
know what i'm going to do abby road i'm
taking back and black
got to be done oh my god
what did you get bill the very
definition of an optimist you don't let
this big sometimes scary world get you
down or ruin your good time
if we could all strive to be a little
more excellent to each other like you
always do
the world would be a less bogus place
you got ted you're a chilled person with
a rock star
soul you're easy going but still
confident in your own abilities
which has gotten you far in life you're
a fantastic friend and the type of loyal
companion
everyone deserves party on we actually
chose our actual selves that's hilarious
well let's just say thanks a lot to
buzzfeed that was fun
i'm kiana reeves i'm alex winter we're
bill and ted
from face the music out on vod and in
theaters
if there are theaters where you are
please go see it or
watch it at home with friends and family
and loved ones
thank you
you